Hey youtubers, charlie here.
Welcome to part one of my many parts preview
for game of thrones season 4.
You thought game of thrones was over for the
year, but I’m going to be doing new game
of thrones videos all year long, so subscribe
and get excited.
Today is a preview of what’s going on in
King’s Landing and what’s going on will
all the main characters there.
Quick recap of Season 3, Tyrion Married Sansa,
Joffrey got engaged to Margaery, and the Queen
of Thrones challenges Tywin in a contest for
the biggest badass in King’s Landing.
That’s only the first half of A Storm of
Swords, so just like the transition from season
2 to season 3, season 4 will begin with aftermath
of the events of the finale.
The have been using the season premiere’s
and season finale’s to book end and resolve
the major conflicts from the oh shit episodes.
So the beginning of season 4 will start off
with the preparations for the purple wedding
and the conflict with the iron islands.
We didn’t see a lot of the Greyjoys in season
3 other than watching the torture porn I like
to call theon’s life right now.
reek it rhymes with freak.
Don’t even get me started on that.
Cersei is supposedly going to marry Loras,
but she doesn’t really seem like someone
who follows orders does she.
Not so much.
In my mind, the real star of king’s landing
in season 4 will be Tyrion.
Peter Dinklage actually had way more speaking
lines in season 3 than in season 2, and almost
more scenes than any other actor on the show,
and that trend is going to continue.
If you remember in season 3, tyrion lost all
his power and basically his character was
on life support.
That’s why he kept trying to find out who
tried to kill him during the battle of blackwater
bay.
It doesn’t get any better.
But in order to find out what happens to tyrion,
you need to understand the purple wedding.
One of The Oh Shit moments of season 3.
There’s a lot of backstabbing and intrigue
that doesn’t make into the show just because
there’s so much stuff, but behind the scenes
The Queen of Thrones has been working to deal
with the Joffrey Problem.
Well she solves it in a very medieval way,
and Tyrion takes the blame.
No one ever suspects the old lady.
That’s probably why they call her the queen
of thorns.
I’m not going to say what happens to joffrey
at the purple wedding, but let me know in
the comments what you think happens.
Just to put it into perspective, Tyrion is
thrown in the black cells and sentenced to
death if it helps you guess.
Spoiler alert!
And what about Sansa?
If you remember pedo-bear Littlefinger has
been creepin’ on her for all of season 3
and in season 4 she finally accepts one of
his escape offers.
Her story will really get interesting in season
5 but I don’t think those moments will make
it into season 4.
What we will see is the return of Jaime and
Brienne to King’s Landing and you’ll have
a lot of fun watching the ‘new’ Jaime
integrate with his family and position of
power.
If you remember, based on his actions you
can kind of imply that he’s a good guy now.
As a result, there’s no more sister-wiving
with Cersei, and since she’s still the same
‘I don’t give a fuck’ character it creates
a lot of really interesting problems.
You’ll also learn why Jaime’s new nickname
is going to be ser jaime of the Golden Hand.
My next season 4 preview video will post on
Thursday, subscribe to get it.
It will cover the characters at the wall like
Jon Snow, Ygritte, The Night’s watch, the
wildlings and the white walkers.
I’ll also be posting a preview of The Hobbit
part 2 the desolation of smaug on tuesday.
In the meantime relive some of the biggest
oh shit moments from season 3 by clicking
here and you can catch up on benedict cumberbatch,
I’ll update the annotation as soon as I
post my smaug video.
The north will remember, high fives.